بدا الجدل يثار حول المصممه الشابه لم
اشتغلت على تطوير محطات المترو فمن ضمن
اللوح اللي صممتها ادعمها فنان تشكيلي
روسي بسرقه اربع لوحات من اعماله
واستخدامها في جداريات محطه مترو كليه
البنات
واصدرت وقتها الهيئه القوميه للانفاق
التابعه لوزاره النقل المصريه بيان اعتذرت
فيه من الفنانه الروسي واكدت على احترامها
للملكيه الفكريه داخل مصر وخارجها وازاله
اللوحه من على محطه المترو
فضلت وقتها غاده والي الصمت وعدم الرد على
الهجوم الكبيره اللي تعرضت له ليعود الجدل
مره اخرى على الساحه مع نفس الفنان الروسي
ولكن المره دي ادعم غاده بسرقه لوحاته
لصالح احدى شركات المياه الغازيه فالشركه
الشهيره اطلقت حمله اعلانيه لترويج مجموعه
محدوده من عبوات المياه الغازيه وتميزت
تلك العبوات بالوان مزركشه ورسومات
مستوحاه من الحضاره والتراث المصري
الفرعوني واللي كانت مشابهه في تحليلها
لرسومات الفنان الروسي ويتجه الفنان
الروسي الى اتخاذ اجراءات قانونيه ضد شركه
المياه الغازيه والمصممه الشابه
المره دي قررت غاده الرد ووضحت ان
الرسومات مستوحاه من المعابد المصريه
الفرعونيه وان وارد جدا ان الافكار تتلاقى
وتتشابه اللوحات بين الفنانين
كل هدفي في الحياه اني ازاي اخلي التصميم
يحيي التراث المصري
فده مش اول مشروع عملوه بيتكلم عن نفس
الفكره دي ولكن اختلف معها بعض المتخصصين
ووضحوا ان في حد بيقف عنده الاقتباس او
توارد الافكار عشان يتحول وقتها لسرقه
التصميم والقاسم الجدل بين مدافع عن غاده
شايف ان الموضوع كله توارث خواطر وان
الاثنين مقتبصين في الاصل من الحضاره
الفرعونيه او على الاقل بيطلبوا بانتظار
رد الجهات المختصه وبين مذكرين بازمه
لوحات المترو واللي بداوا يشككوا في كل
اعمال غاده السابقه بما فيها شعار حفل
افتتاح طريق الكباش وبيطالبه باصدار بيان
توضيح من شركه المياه الغازيه حيال هذا
الامر
[موسيقى]
وانتم مع من تتفقون انا مش هسيب حقي
وبحترم شغلي اللي فات واللي جاي